- This is a Ford Model T from 1911
and under the hood, it's hiding a secret.
See, this car is actually
an electric vehicle.
It was recently converted from
gas to electric by this man,
80 year old former electic
model engineer, Robert Knight.
And it's not just Robert or antique Fords.
As EV adoption increases around the globe,
a string of startups
have emerged with the aim
of retrofitting and upcycling
gas cars into electric ones.
(gentle music)
Okay, so firstly, what's
it take to convert a car?
Well, as Robert found out, it's
both simple and really hard.
- So the initial conversion was a year,
but since then I've been
modifying it and modifying it,
and I've had mistake after mistake.
- [George Downs] Step one
is to drain the fuel tank
and completely remove the engine block.
That can create a space where batteries
and an electric motor can be installed.
Next is the task of hooking
that motor up to the drivetrain
and wiring in a battery management system.
After that, it's just a case of hooking
up the new drivetrain to the
controls, or in Robert's case,
installing these various switches.
Ford purists, look away now.
- I've had one or two adverse comments
about wrecking a 1911 Ford Model T.
- [George Downs] Robert
tells me he's managed
to get around 25 miles of
range out of his conversion,
which is just enough to get him
to the local shops and back.
And the conversion cost, under $2,000,
most of which came from
the sale of the engine.
- So it's trivial, absolutely trivial.
- [George Downs] So if it's possible
to do a relatively cheap
conversion yourself,
is it possible to make
money from doing it?
To find out, I've come to UK based
EV upcycling startup, Lunaz.
Each of these cars may look
like an original classic car
but they've actually all
been completely stripped
and rebuilt from the ground up
with a brand new electric powertrain.
That's the only bit of that
car I can afford to touch.
That's because the starting
price for the conversion
of these classics is
around $370,000 and up,
which is around the same price
as buying a competition condition classic.
But it's not just classic
cars that Lunaz is upcycling.
They're also taking
commercial fleet vehicles
like these garbage trucks
and running them through a
similar upcycling process.
Here's CEO David Lorenz.
- Some of the trucks behind me today,
these are seven year old vehicles.
They have done a hundred thousand miles
over their seven year life.
They were tried and tested by
the OEM for a million miles.
Fundamentally, it is so
logical to upcycle the vehicle
that already exists to
clean their powertrain.
- David told me that for Lunaz,
upcycling actually presents
a faster route to market
and means that their
trucks can be thousands
of dollars cheaper than
buying a new EV equivalent.
- We do 80% less work.
All of the bumpers,
windscreen wipers, mechanisms,
we don't have to face these challenges.
These vehicles have
been so well engineered
in the first place.
- [George Downs] The main
reason David founded Lunaz was
that he believes by upcycling
you can remove more carbon
dioxide from the loop
than if you buy new EVs.
- If you go and replace 5,000 vehicles
with clean air powertrain vehicles,
that's fantastic in one sense.
But what happens to
your old 5,000 vehicles?
They're gonna end up on cargo ships.
They're gonna end up in
less privileged countries,
and they're gonna sweat longer hours
than you were using them for,
naturally producing more emissions.
- So if retrofitting and
upcycling could potentially
present a faster path towards
hitting climate targets,
and there are businesses out
there making money from it,
why aren't more OEMs doing it?
Well, companies like Ford and GM
have made some tentative
steps into retrofitting
by offering electric versions
of certain components.
But according to Patrick
Hertzke, automotive analyst
and partner at McKinsey,
automakers have bigger fish to fry.
- They have their hands full scaling up
standard EV production,
getting gigafactory supply
of batteries within their supply chain,
trying to drive costs down.
- Another reason is that
releasing retrofitting options
could potentially sabotage
sales of new cars,
as some customers may choose
to retrofit instead of replace.
But possibly the biggest reason is
that it can be very hard to turn a profit
from retrofitting everyday vehicles.
After all, while these classic cars
and garbage trucks may
look very different,
they're both expensive enough
to make retrofitting worth it.
The classic cars retain value
and there's economies of scale
in retrofitting a small
fleet of identical vehicles.
Or as David said...
- There is no vehicle
that can't be upcycled
to clean air powertrain.
It's just, is it a cost
effective solution?
What is the cost to this?
- But there may be something
that could help shift the balance
and make retrofitting
more popular; subsidies.
- The extent that these retrofitters
can fully access
additional subsidy schemes
or regulatory encouragement
can certainly have an impact.
- And if you wanna know
what that might look like,
it's already happening in France.
There, retrofitted electric
vehicles are eligible
for a few thousand dollars
in government subsidies,
and you have companies
like Renault teaming up
with retrofitter R-FIT
to offer conversions
of cheaper classic vehicles and startups
like Transition-One offering
conversions on light city cars.
But here's the thing, even with subsidies
it can be really hard to turn a profit.
While I was reporting this story,
Transition-One stopped
trading as the company said
it no longer had the
financial means to continue.
So without significant
government incentives
it's unlikely you'll see OEMs getting
into the retrofitting game anytime soon.
But keep an eye on those
retrofitting startups
'cause they can have a lot
of vehicles to work with.
While EVs may have made up 10%
of all new car sales last
year, they're still a fraction
of the estimated 1.4 billion
vehicles on the planet.
(gentle music)